they don't look like much but these
little bottles are likely way out of
this pandemic
if and when covered vaccines are
approved this is where they'll be made
this actually contains the vaccine but
until we're saved by the science
the prime minister controlling the virus
with a blunter tool
keeping us bottled up in a tiered
regional lockdown
many people frustrated we can't afford
to let it out of control again so the
tiering system
is tough but it's designed to be
tough and to keep it under control and i
know that
lots of people think that they are in
the wrong tier
and and i understand people's
frustration but rules people think
are unfair are tough to follow this mp
whose constituents are moving into tier
3
is worried about compliance you're less
likely to have that
if people think rules in that form
shouldn't apply to them so that's what
really worries me about the system
so you think that the government are
being too strict they're not applying
enough common sense
and the public therefore will ignore the
rules
if people think the rules shouldn't be
applied
that strictly to them they will try and
find ways around them and that would
make
the situation worse the situation could
get worse for boris johnson too as
dozens of his own mps weigh up whether
to support the government
or reject the new tears the state of the
economy when we come out of this
will have a huge impact on people's
lives on their chances of finding a job
on the chance of getting what they want
to get for their families and for
themselves
skeptical mps have been asking the
government for weeks to publish an
economic impact assessment
and tonight the government has done that
but it's a pretty thin document
indeed one mp lead in the rebellion told
me it was rather less substantial
than they'd hoped for so the big
question is
will it win over enough rebels or will
boris johnson have to look to labour
to get these measures across the line
the pm hopes he'll have a remedy to
quell rebellions pretty soon
but in the meantime his tears not going
down well at all back in westminster
beth rigby sky news